Let's go next to Aaron from
California. Aaron, you're on the air.
Aaron from California, you're on the air.
Can you hear me? Yes, I can. Hey, awesome.
Well, my question is kind of like a bit more
broad, I guess, because after obviously I mean,
we can all agree, like the last two or three
months has been like an insane amount of like just
pure disinformation from the Republican Party.
Yeah. Across the board. So I'm wondering,
obviously, this is kind of a long shot, but would
it be possible for like a type of regulation
that we kind of say like, hey, I like all
types of like new upcoming social media
companies are established to have like
either like a chief scientific officer
or like some type of panel of these
companies that goes through like
what's in the media, what's being what's
being spoken about and reported and see like
what is the obvious types of disinformation
that, like, these companies can try and stop.
Now, I don't see any shot at that whatsoever.
I don't think there's any legal basis for it.
And I also don't think it's the right way to
fight disinformation. I've said this before
in different formats or with different
framings. And I'll say it again,
the solution to disinformation, conspiracy
theories, antiscience, anti vax, delusional.
Q And on Fox News, on Newsmax, Rush Limbaugh,
Mark Levin, Alex Jones to all that stuff.
The solution is better educated people teaching
media literacy early, creating a culture where
people have a healthy skepticism when they
are given information by something that
may be the news or maybe just looks like news.
I don't think that we I just I don't believe and
I've seen no evidence that we can regulate our
way out of the disinformation, ignorance crisis.
Yeah, yeah, for sure, I mean, because I think the
big thing is like I mean, we've seen like just
everything escalate in terms of disinformation
so, so exponentially over the last few years
that it feels like, at least to me. But I don't
know, like obviously we could I fully agree with a
lot of like educating the populace over time. But
it like there's so many people that it would take
so long. It would seem that here's the thing.
Here's the thing. It took four. I've been I've
been repeating this a lot because it's important
to understand it took 40 years for things to get
this bad. It's going to take a long time
to fix it. And we have to be OK with that.
We just have to improve, because the only way
you can quickly change something as big as what
you're talking about is via dictatorship.
And we don't want to be a dictatorship.
And so I think we just have to concede it's going
to take a while to fix this. And that's it. It's
not that it's OK. We'd rather fix it more quickly,
but we don't really have a choice in a democracy.
Yeah, of course. All right,
well, thank you, David.
I appreciate it. Thank you so much. There
is another perfect phone call for lack of
a better term. Let's go next to oh, there's
just so many people that want to get on here.
Why don't we go to is that Mary or Mary from
the San Francisco Bay Area? Murray or Murray,
please unmuted yourself, and then I'll be able to
talk to you. Murray or Murray, please, on mute,
you were on the air and this is the last
chance. All right, Murray or Murray is done